this house located in the beautiful
Mountain Village of asago Japan is free
not free to the 1 millionth visitor free
not free except for these terms and
conditions free
just free
some of the top amenities include these
ruins of a 15th century Castle a mere
20-minute scenic drive away
and everything from cherry blossom trees
to a supermarket post office and hair
salon all within walking distance
now the building itself is no five-star
hotel it could use more than a Fresh
coat of paint
but at nearly 1400 square feet with two
stories flush toilets and heating there
are worse ways to spend zero dollars
more remarkable perhaps is the fact that
this deal isn't all that remarkable
there are at least 8 million such
abandoned homes across Japan
some free and others effectively free
just waiting for someone to claim them
maybe the island lifestyle is more your
speed in which case you might be
interested in this one for about 5 000
US dollars
if you're looking to splurge a bit this
one could be yours for 11 Grand the
possibilities are endless
you can have your pick between about one
in every seven houses including the land
11 of the entire country's surface area
and there's no hurry these numbers are
expected to double by 2033.
that's right in just 10 years time
nearly every third Japanese home will be
vacant according to the country's
largest economic research institute
and while its population is among the
fastest shrinking in the world
demography alone cannot explain these
strange real estate Dynamics
sponsored by curiositystream and nebula
watch my six-part exclusive series and
other nebula Originals like great cities
with the Curiosity stream and nebula
bundle all for just 15 bucks a year
broadly speaking there are two ways to
make housing more affordable increase
Supply or decrease demand
Japan uniquely does both
for one demography certainly doesn't
hurt
its population has been declining since
2010 and is expected to return to 1970
levels within the next 25 years
fewer people means fewer households
means fewer homes
that's on the demand side
but Supply is no less important
to put it simply Japan builds like crazy
Tokyo proper for instance has a
population of about 14 million people
New York City a little less than nine
but despite being only 1.6 times more
populous Tokyo built four and a third
times as many houses in 2020. of course
as any Californian can tell you just
build more is easier said than done
increasing Supply is threatening to the
very parties responsible for its
approval neighbors City councils and
local governments
but that's where the Japanese system
excels
during the late 80s and early 90s the
country experienced a housing bubble
that rivals 2008.
at one point all the land in Japan was
valued four times higher than all of
America despite being 26 times smaller
in land area about the size of Montana
alone
after the market Came Crashing Down the
government made changes to prevent the
same thing from happening again
the tiny difference that makes all the
difference is that in Japan land policy
is now mostly set at the national not
local level
its Ministry of land infrastructure
transportation and tourism is less like
say the little-known federal Maritime
commission and more akin to the
all-powerful EPA
it rather than partial local governments
or even the legislature itself largely
dictates the country's building codes
for example
cities are only permitted to divide
their land into zones the national
government decides what can and can't be
built in each one
the United States has no fewer than 22
000 sets of codes each one with dozens
of different zones
the entire nation of Japan meanwhile is
divided into just 12 total and any
changes made to one of them applies
everywhere
another seemingly minor difference with
major Downstream effects is the way
these zones work
while a commercial Zone in America
typically allows only commercial
activity things like auto repair shops
movie theaters and strip malls the same
one in Japan also allows for
non-commercial uses like apartments and
schools what this means is that
developers are free if they want to mix
uses
that free house in asago for instance is
about 30 feet from a hair salon and a
three-minute walk from a bookstore
in Japan your neighbors really have no
say over what you do with your property
a degree of Freedom that results in some
pretty quirky design choices
on the tame end of the spectrum there's
the stuff of HOA nightmares you might
find a traditional wooden house directly
adjacent to a modern minimalist mansion
then there are the truly creative ones
the gothic tomato Cottages transparent
townhouses and giant pyramids if you can
dream it it can surely be built
one consequence is that Japan produces
more Architects per capita than any
other country and by a wide margin five
times more than the UK seven times more
than America and 11 times more than
Canada
it's hard to imagine a better place for
young Architects to experiment than a
nation of tiny homes free from concerns
about neighborhood character
but wait a second
four times as many new homes as New York
these numbers aren't just impressive
they're too impressive
think about it this way here are seven
large advanced economies
this is each one's total population
and this is the number of new homes each
one builds in a typical year
one country clearly stands out
how can it be that Japan with only 40
percent as many people builds almost as
many new homes each year as the United
States
we all know California is starved for
housing but this is just crazy the math
doesn't add up
the solution to this puzzle it turns out
lies in the number of existing homes
sold
now we can see that although the total
number of homes sold in each country
both new and used is roughly
proportional to its population there's a
huge difference in composition
the vast majority of American home sales
are second hand whereas the vast
majority of Japanese home sales are
brand new
in fact if we stretch the data out we
can see that it's almost the inverse of
America
and that's Japan's secret the reason its
housing market is so fundamentally
different
it's not just about National control of
zoning it's also an entirely different
perspective on what housing is
in most advanced economies a house is an
investment that doubles as a place to
live
8401 K you can sleep in
in Japan a house is a consumer good not
unlike a car or a refrigerator that
rapidly depreciates in value
in a mere 30 years the typical Japanese
home goes from brand new to about as
valuable as a CD player in 2023
that's no exaggeration according to the
ministry of land even a reinforced
concrete apartment has a lifespan of
just 37 years
try to sell your house on the 38th year
and banks will tell you it's worth zero
dollars or less since the building has
to be demolished before a new one can be
built
as you can see here used homes
depreciate on average over twice as fast
in Japan as in the U.S
one reason for this is relatively
straightforward earthquakes
not only did they destroy homes but they
require periodic updates to building
codes to better prepare for the next one
newer buildings are considered much
safer
another reason has to do with history
nearly a third of Urban Japanese homes
were bombed during the second world war
creating a shortage of 4 million units
and when private Banks were unable to
keep up with demand from mortgages the
government was forced to step in
starting in June of 1950 generously
subsidized interest rates were offered
to anyone in need of a home
these millions of dollars of stimulus
redirected from the war helped pay for
nearly 20 million units by 2007.
but this overwhelming success came with
an unintended side effect
in the rush to house war-torn Japan
building standards even those of the
1950s were haphazardly overlooked
these were cheap wooden houses with poor
insulation and sometimes major
structural flaws
because of this they tended to last just
three or four decades before they had to
be completely destroyed and rebuilt from
the ground up the end result was a
persistent widespread practice that
lasts to this day
the quality of today's homes of course
hardly resembles those of 1950.
there's no reason any built this decade
if well cared for couldn't survive well
beyond 30 years
but because they're valued like fragile
consumer goods owners have little
incentive to put in the necessary
maintenance turning the 30-year lifespan
into a self-fulfilling prophecy
meanwhile until 2015 homeowners had
little incentive to demolish any houses
they weren't living in thanks to another
Legacy of World War II
also to increase the supply of housing
small residential plots were taxed 80
percent less if they contained a
structure
that 1400 square foot home from earlier
would be taxed at just 75 dollars a year
for example
it's exactly these kinds of seemingly
minor historical details that shape the
cities we live in today and in great
cities Dave from City beautiful explains
how for Shanghai Canberra and Paris
great cities like my six-part series
China actually along with dozens of
others on topics like urbanism politics
and modern history are exclusively
available on today's sponsor nebula
signing up to nebula is the absolute
best way to support independent creators
like polymatter and the cheapest way to
get access is with the Curiosity stream
bundle using the link in the description
after signing up to curiositystream for
just 15 bucks a year you'll get an email
with instructions on how to get free
access to nebula on curiositystream you
can watch feature length documentaries
like this one about how a single Bridge
forever changed Japan
click the link on screen right now to
get both nebula and curiosity stream
from your 15 a year